uh welcome again to this uh
webinar section on big data and hadoop
right so for today's session uh we would
be covering
uh the basics of big data so this is the
agenda that we are
targeting for today's session right
before i start let me just introduce
myself my name is jamin patel
i have over 10 years of software
industry experience
and i have worked with couple of product
companies uh developing softwares i have
been working in various technologies
java j2e
and over the last three years i got an
opportunity to
get my hands dirty on big data
technologies and that's where
i get a chance to work on hadoop and
since last three years i have been
working every day using hadoop
technologies and we we solve a lot of
business problems using big data
platforms we have in fact built one
analytics platform where we
uh
we do a lot of analytics and we run a
lot of analytics jobs which provides uh
analytical services to the customers
apart from that i also like to
uh you know have a conferences open
conferences with people who are
like-minded and who want to share and do
something innovative
in the big data space
so we conduct a lot of
conferences and open house sessions in
the similar area
uh
and i also uh possess a tremendous
interest in sharing the
knowledge that i have gained over years
for big data technologies with the
people who are interested to learn about
that and that is the reason we are
meeting here
he's starting with understanding big
data where
if you can if you if you
if you think uh for a minute
any new technology or any new thing that
we want to learn
we need to first
understand or we need to first make sure
that we get
two questions answered clearly
which is what is that thing that we need
to learn
and why we need to learn that or why we
should learn that right
so that is what i'm going to focus on
today
by covering understanding big data now
once we
cover that we will understand
all right
big data is definitely uh an important
area where you know lot of companies are
investing
a huge amount of money
so what are the technologies and tools
available to work with big data which
can help us
solve some of the business use cases
with big data
and
that is where we will introduce hadoop
in this group right and we understand
the high level definition of what is
hadoop
and why it is used right
and
the last of last part of the session
will be covering hadoop ecosystem so
i'll be just touching upon some of the
keywords
that you i'm sure you would have already
heard about
which creates hadoop ecosystem
okay
now
before i uh uh you know start taking the
each topic and explaining that uh
let me know if anyone has any questions
you can always uh you know post your
questions and
uh as we just discussed uh the
simplyland team would definitely get
back to me they will tell me the
questions and we will respond we will
address those questions
as in when it is uh asked right uh so we
will also give you uh last five minutes
of the session where you know the there
will be question answers and if people
want to ask specific questions or they
have any specific doubts they can always
uh you know get it clarified
so all right uh let's talk about big
data and let's understand what is big
data
so as the name suggests right if we
really want to understand what is big
data the first thing which comes to our
mind right by reading the
word itself is is lots and lots of data
it's about
volume that that comes to our mind right
a massive amount of data about terabytes
and petabytes of data
but can i say if i have huge volume of
data i have big data
uh now that's where we
really need to pause for a while and
let me
introduce some of the real world
scenarios to you
and before we formally define what is
big data okay so i have captured some of
the slides here uh some of the images uh
from different industry sectors uh first
image is an airline aeroplane right so
basically an airline industries
uh you know they are how they are using
big data and what are they trying to do
with that
so
the stat says that an airline jet
collects about 10 terabytes of sensor
data for every 30 minutes of flying time
right so which is which is a massive
volume so if you can see
about 30 minutes of flying time and
airline can collect so much data because
they have
something called a blacks box system
in the plane
which records
they they have a lot of sensors attached
to it and those
sensors
records
each and every event that happens during
the flying time
right so now what they do is by
collecting so much information this
information is a very very valuable
information
and what they do is they actually
do they analyze this information they
process this data
to solve some of the business use case
i'm sure there will be lot of business
use cases uh but we will not go in in
each and every use case that airline
industry is all right so what we do is
i'll just take one use case which could
be you know uh to improve the quality or
performance of a fly flight right
how do we make sure that the
the flight time and the the
performance is cost effective
so
that is a major problem that is i would
say a major business use case for any
airline industry
and if they want to i mean if they solve
that definitely they'll get a lot of
profit so these informations will help
them solving that business use case
right how they are solving it we would
not cover in today's session we would
definitely talk about how part of it uh
when we get into the actual trainings
right uh let me also talk about another
use case which is
uh about stock exchange right so i have
just uh put a
image of new york stock exchange
and
that image
is i mean as everyone i'm sure everyone
is aware of uh you know stock exchange
uh people trade stocks they just trade
it
day in day out they sell and buy stocks
of different companies right
so even the stock exchanges with such
heavy transactions
they generate terabytes of data
per day right
now if you can see there is a
lots and lots of valuable information in
terms of this transaction which is being
generated every day now there are
specific analytics company available who
who are actually interested in
predicting the market trends or
predicting the value of a stock of any
particular company
so what they do is they actually write
high frequency trading algorithms
and these algorithms are fed
with lots of data which these stock
exchanges generated over a period of
time
and based on that this algorithm
predicts how this stock is going to
perform
over next couple of days or next couple
of months
based on the previous past historical
record that it has
with with the stock exchange right so
these companies will actually uh you
know try to perform uh stock trading
analytics to determine
optimal trends
right for any particular stock
and and they do this using definitely
hadoop as one of the technologies
with which they try to uh solve such
business problems right
uh let us go to another example uh right
facebook
i'm sure everybody uses facebook every
day right it's kind of it has become a
part of our life
people do a lot of social networking
these days and they get connected to
various friends families relatives
now i am not going to explain what we
can do with facebook but
the important fact that i have gathered
here which says
uh you know facebook has about billion
users across the globe
and
about
250 300 plus million users
in the u.s itself
the united states of america so what i'm
trying to highlight here is facebook has
huge and huge amount of users right
now facebook has published a state which
says that every 20 minutes on facebook
lot of activities happens and i'm just
going to draw you draw uh some
some of the
important part here which is like you
know you do link shared event divides
friend request accepted photos uploaded
messages said
so all these activities that you are
doing
right and and when
all the users across the globe are doing
these activities in every 20 minutes on
facebook so you can say that so much
data is getting generated every 20
minutes right
so that's a massive amount of data that
we are talking about
now what facebook does with this data so
facebook actually uh by the way facebook
has lot of revenue streams but
one of the revenue model that facebook
has is
through advertisements right
so what they do is
they
analyze the data that they have for a of
a particular user so
every user has a facebook profile right
and every user does a lot of things
on facebook
and that defines the behavior the
character and the you know nature of
that user i mean what that that user
likes what that user does not like
cover here is an advertisement as a use
case
so uh before i get into how facebook
does the advertisement i also want to
tell you one thing which is
if you can see about 10 years or 15
years back there was an era of
advertisement where
uh you know
people used to show
advertisements for any particular
product or a brand
uh
to
generic set of users they don't really
care whether a particular user was
interested to see that advertisement or
not
right and that type of advertisement is
called mass advertisement
so earlier days the mass advertisement
was very prevalent in the market even
these days if you see on televisions
uh everybody has televisions in their
home and if you see
two people sitting in different
geographical location watching
the same channel same program on the tv
may see
the similar ads same ads on the same
time
right uh it it may so happen that one of
the user would not be interested in in
seeing particular ad but the other other
user might be interested but
irrespective of whether a user is
interested or not
still he has to see the ad right
so that is called mass advertisement now
what facebook did facebook with the you
know invention of this analytics uh
and and and with the help of these
technologies related to big data what
they did is they analyzed this data and
they came up with a beautiful concept
called targeted advertisement
which means
rather than showing an advertisement to
a mass set of user now they are showing
an advertisement to a particular user
right so what they do is
they analyze the data of a user they
understand the interest likes and
dislike of that particular user so now
they know exactly what i should what
advertisement i should show to this user
so that he or she may be interested to
do some transaction with that product or
that company
so for example if a user who who's doing
a lot of activities on sport who has
uploaded a lot of videos and and photos
related to sports events
or you know who's actually doing a lot
of who's joining a lot of sports groups
attending lot of sports events all these
informations are there on the facebook
page so
facebook has analyzed this data and
found out that okay this user is pretty
interested in sports activity so let us
show him an advertisement related to
sports brands or if any sport event is
happening let us show him the
advertisement for for that event and and
chances of that user going to that
particular page visits and doing some
transition would be very high
and that is how you know uh
facebook increases the chances of
generating revenue because
when once a user clicks on to this
advertisement on every click facebook
gets some share of revenue from this
advertisement companies
apart from that if a user goes and visit
those pages and does some transaction
facebook gets a revenue so if you can
now relate
i'm sure you will you will appreciate
this that it is very important for face
book to do this analysis very accurately
right so that they can increase the
revenue increase the chances of their
revenue by making more accurate analysis
and that is why they have to do this
accurate analysis using the technologies
related to big data
and and facebook also by the way is
using
uh massive clusters which are running on
hadoop okay so in during our actual
training sessions i would be covering uh
some of the use cases of facebook and
will understand how they use that
so that's one part of facebook and since
we are talking about facebook i also
want to highlight one very important
deal which uh which has happened a
couple of months back
uh that facebook has taken over
uh whatsapp right i'm sure everyone
knows that so
i'm sure everyone knows
why they have taken over but i just want
to highlight that point if someone has
taken over whatsapp
they really really need to understand
why such a massive deal happen about 19
million dollars
because
facebook it's not that because of the
software they paid that price
facebook could have developed whatsapp
like messenger very fast and probably
better quality
but they paid the price not for the
software they paid the price for the
amount of data that whatsapp already had
because they have well lot of healthy
information from different users their
contact details and lots and lots of
information of these
billions of users registered users and
that is the asset that facebook wanted
and that is where they did they paid a
hefty price for that so that is just a
use case that i just wanted to highlight
so basically again facebook paid a huge
price for data basically acquiring a
data
okay
so that's another use case uh similar
use case is twitter where again twitter
also does the
uh a similar thing where any company who
want to market their product uh can go
on to twitter and basically market their
product twitter can face them the right
set of users who are interested to buy
their product because
they also do a lot of analysis over the
data that they have for a particular
user
so twitter also follows the similar
model and they are also using a lot of
analytics using big data okay
so these are some of the use cases that
these companies solve using big data
technologies
now let us define big data let us
formally define what is big data data so
ibms are the ones who
came up with the big data definition who
has formally defined what is big data
so by the way you can characterize the
big data into three different buckets
uh the volume the velocity and variety
right
uh so
if you really want to so let us
understand uh each bucket so
volume means as the name suggests it's
actually you know huge amount of data
it's about terabytes and petabytes of
data
so
once you have huge amount of data
remember we
talked about
do we can we say we have a big data
but the answer is no we really need to
also look into other parameters another
parameter is velocity which means
if you have a huge volume of data at
what speed that data gets generated into
your system
or that data comes to your system
right
so let me give you an example let's say
you have about terabyte of data which
gets generated in your system after
every let's say one year right that is
one use case one scenario
uh and now the another scenario is let's
say you have one
terabyte of data which gets generated
into your system
after every one day okay
now you can see the difference in terms
of the
frequency right
once use case we have one terabyte of
data gets accumulated into our system
after every one year and another use
case every day such huge amount of data
keeps coming to my system right so
definitely velocity plays a major role
right so first case would definitely not
fit into big data because we are really
talking about higher velocity
uh the third bucket of big data is
called variety which means
what type of data we are handling or we
are talking about right so by the way at
a high level
you can categorize
the big data into three different
buckets
any type of
of data into three different buckets
which is structured data unstructured
data and semi-structured data
so let me just spend one minute to
define what are these
structural data means
any data that you can store
on a relational database systems like
your you know normal otps like oracle
mysql server sql server mysql and and
all that
so these are the the data which gets
stored in the table rows and column
format are called structure data
then what is unstructured data
unstructured data means any let's say
images photos videos
audio songs audio files video files all
these type of data are called
unstructured data
even the log files that get generated by
application servers these are also
unstructured data why because
space
so
by the way xml files or i would say json
files are the very good example for
semi-structured data because they
represent the information in the form of
you know xml files represent tags where
you can define tags in a hierarchical
order means there is some relationship
between them
but the value that you put inside each
tag can be anything so that is
unstructured part of it so that's why
you have some structure and some
unstructured part and that is why xml is
is an example of semi-structured data
so if i want to summarize uh what is big
data you can just say that if you have
huge amount huge volume of data about
terabytes or petabytes of data which
gets generated into your system very
rapidly and it can contain any type of
data
then you can say you have a big data
that is the formal definition of big
data okay
uh so i just want to put a pause here
and
really
wait for a couple of seconds to just
check if someone has any questions for
me
simply learn team can you please confirm
if someone ask any questions
so
all right looks like uh
looks like we don't have uh
uh if we have we will definitely uh get
back to you so let me continue forward
all right so
this slide talks about unstructured data
explosion which means
if you can see this slide you will
realize that
early
2000 or late 1990s
till till that point of time
actually the data volume was very less
only the transaction data was there
across the globe but if you can see from
early 2000
onwards the data
curve is actually exploding like this
which is basically a hockey stick growth
okay
and and
that is the massive
uh you know that actually leads to the
massive opportunities related to big
data a lot of companies have
shown lot of opportunities in this space
uh that they can do to remain competent
in the market or gain the competitive
advantage over their competitors
right uh there are some stats that i
have just captured here which says that
digital universe grew about 62 percent
last year and it will grow to about 1.20
zetabyte this year which means every
year the massive volume of data is
getting accumulated
and which leads to lots and lots more
possibilities related to big data right
one of the primary driver
for this growth is internet right
nowadays everybody has lot of widgets
and gadgets through which they can
connect to the
internet and they actually
do lots and lots of information uh they
share they upload photos videos lot of
they do lot of activities on internet
and they basically
increase the volume uh which is
specified here right
with that kind of activities so that is
the this is basically an informative
slide which talks about
the growth of the data every year
okay
so now let us try and understand
i just got a comment from simplyland
team that some of the participants
cannot hear me
can you please confirm from
can you please confirm from other
participants who can hear me well
can you hear me well by the way
so
how about now is it better
okay
can you just check with all the
participants if they can hear
me
all right
okay
uh all right everyone so what we
understood as of now is uh what is big
data so can you please check with the
team if anyone has any questions as of
now or everybody understood whatever we
have covered so far
can you just quickly uh
confirm me that
okay all right
uh so let me continue forward uh so
basically now we have understood what is
big data now we will be
understanding
why big data is
so much important right so i'll just
take i have gathered couple of use cases
from different industry sectors now what
i'll be doing is i'll be actually
covering only
uh some of the important use cases for
today's session and when we get into the
actual training we will get into the
details of each and every use cases
right
so if you can see uh there are different
industry sectors like web and retailing
telecom finance so let us talk about uh
the use case from this industry sectors
and understand how they are using big
data technologies to solve such use
cases solve such problems
one of the use cases
these companies when you do online
shopping right
the next time when you do any shopping
with this company when you log into that
website page they will already have the
transaction history that you have done
with them earlier and based on that they
analyze the data and they recommend you
set of products right so if you can see
they you they will show you which
products are
important and which products are are
basically you would be interested in
buying so you will most of the time you
will you know come to know you will you
will realize that
the transaction that you have done
already with these companies
uh the kind of product that you have
already bought with these companies they
will be recommending you the similar
products from the similar category and
also the the similar price range right
and that is where this recommendation
engine use case comes into picture so
what this company does is they run lot
of machine learning algorithms on top of
this data
and they try to
build this intelligence over the data
and find out whether user is a part but
is particularly interested in in which
all product categories
and what price range he's looking to buy
the product for right
by the way recommendations is one of the
area of machine learning
and lot of algorithms are there to solve
different problems in that area
so these e-commerce companies uses these
algorithms to solve such use cases now
what they
the stats say is that this kind of
recommendation use case uh that they are
actually showing to the customers
it will give them about 60 to 70 percent
hit ratio which means let's say a person
who's logging into this websites
and who tries to let's say if you if a
user who logs into a amazon website and
he will be recommending some products uh
by the website
uh even if the user who's not interested
to or who has not made up his mind to
buy any product
by looking at this recommended products
the chances of him doing end up doing
any transaction
would be about 60 to 70 percentage right
and that is actually a massive
passive marketing i would say
which they are doing and that is very
very important thing for the business so
that is one such use cases that they are
solving let me take one more use cases
from another industry sector which is
telecommunication
which is called customer churn
prevention if you can see here
this is the use case i am talking about
customer channel prevention
so
these telecom communications industries
what they do is uh they basically
have you know they are the telecom
service providers to different different
users now let me i let me just take some
examples let's say there are two
companies
company a and company b these are the
two telecom service provider companies
in united states of america
now
these companies what they do is let's
say there are users who are using
services from company a and there are
some users who are using services from
company b now it may happen that some of
the users who are using services from
company a may leave them and join
company b or start using services from
company b because they were not
satisfied with the
services that is provided by company a
or they may not get the correct network
coverage or they may be
the price range would be very higher or
they may got you know competitive prices
from their competitors there could be
various reasons why they are leaving
them so what this company does is the
the company a would actually have all
the details about why their customers
have left them and they analyze these
reasons
uh by again using these technologies to
find out what are the top 10 reasons why
majority of my customers are leaving us
right
and they try to come up with a better
competitive offers or better
solutions to those reasons those
problems to make sure that
we can avoid such customer churns
in future right by solving those
problems
and that is one very good way of
retaining your customers right it is
very important for any business to
retain their customers and that is how
they do it using this technology
so that is one such use cases that i
wanted to talk about
okay
now similarly you have lot of such use
cases let me talk to tell you about one
of the use cases that
uh that is being handled in in the
government by government of india
it is called aadhar card so people who
don't know what is other card it is it
is very similar to a social security
number that you have in united states of
america
which is like a unique id for every
citizen in that country right so this
passive project got implemented about
few years back and now many all the
people are having this unique id with
them
so the implementation of this entire
project is being done using hadoop and
edge base as the underlying technologies
right and by the way other card is
called
the world's biggest biometric database
just because of the sheer volume of the
data that it has or it has to process
from this country right so that is also
one such use case where these
technologies are heavily used
another industry sector
is health care and life sciences where
you have gene lot of use cases that can
be solved i'll just talk about one of
the use cases called drug safety
so any pharmaceutical company when they
release a drug right what they do is
they actually tie up with big hospitals
and they release that product to them
now these hospitals doctors in that
hospital will prescribe these drugs to
the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
okay so what happens is basically they
are actually
you know
marketing these drugs and after this
drug has been
applied to different patients
over about six months or one year these
companies collect this data from
different hospitals and they analyze
this data to find out how this drug has
performed over number of period right
and based on that they take a decision
whether to improve the drug or whether
to you know
add more ingredients or whether to
completely remove this drug and come up
with a better version so such questions
they they try to answer by analyzing
this data so that is one such use case
where uh healthcare and pharmaceutical
companies are also using big data
heavily right
uh another use case uh that i would take
up uh from bank and financial services
which is called
credit scoring and analysis
i'm sure many people know about credit
scoring so i'll not talk about how
credit scoring is derived
but credit scoring and analysis is
actually one such use case where
banks rely it on heavily before they
give loans to any customers right so i'm
sure everyone knows about credit score
so every individual will have their
credit score based on the financial
wealth and financial history that they
have with the different banks
now
once they have this credit score when a
user goes to a goes for a loan to any
particular bank what this bank does is
they actually check all this historical
data
of this user and they they
they can easily get this data
fro from all the banks where this fuser
is holding an account because these days
all the banks are centralized so they
can easily get this data and they can
analyze this data to find out what is
his income pattern and what is his
spending pattern and based on that they
come up with a
uh
analysis saying that
whether this particular person he will
be able to repay the emi in a given
period of time right
so even the user may not know how much
money he would have or she would have
after period of after some months of
time or one year of time but with this
analysis banks can
give you that answer right so that is
where banks are also just to get this
analysis
then correctly they are using these
technologies
big data technologies heavily
okay so these are some of the use cases
that i wanted to talk about in the
interest of time i would probably not go
in detail about that but definitely
during our training we will
various real world use cases across
different industry sectors right so i
hope everyone is fine as of now
and and then i'll just spend couple of
more minutes and understand in
in covering the remaining topics
so before i move further
is anyone has any questions
okay
okay looks like we don't have so good so
let's move forward
these are some of the hadoop users that
you know
you may have heard about these are some
of the big names in the industry
but there are lots and lots of companies
who are using hadoop the list is very
huge okay
so now we have understood what is big
data and why big data is so much
important now let us understand
what are the technologies that can
help us work with big data
and how hadoop has become the most
effective technology to
work with big data in the interest of
time i would not cover in detail of that
but what i will cover is
what is hadoop and how it works with big
data right so before i go into hadoop
i'll just spend few minutes in
explaining
what is distributed file system because
when you talk about hadoop hadoop is a
framework which
gives you two important features
one is to store data in a distributed
manner and another one is to process the
data in a distributed manner right so
when i say distributed manner it is
nothing but underlying system that
hadoop uses to store the data is nothing
but distributed file system so let us
understand why it uses distributed file
system right so i have just given two
different use cases if you can see here
you have one use case where you have one
machine
each machine has four i o channels and
100 mbps speed
now if i want to read one terabyte of
data which is stored on a
single machine
how much time does it take so let us say
it
it takes about
45 minutes right let us know not go into
the calculation of how it has taken that
but let us assume that okay it has taken
45 minutes now there is another use case
where it has already spoken uh where
let's say
instead of taking one machine what if i
store
this data into 10 different machines
okay
so
each machine by the way the
configuration remains the same they will
have four i o channels and each channel
will have 100 mbps speed
okay so let
say if you divide your data or
distribute your data into 10 different
machines and then now if you want to
read one terabyte of data we can
definitely read it using
parallelization so how much time it will
take it takes about 4.5 minutes okay
so which is much faster
so that is one of the fundamental reason
why distributed file system exists why
it is needed okay
now what is distributed file system
so the distributed file system is
nothing but it's a virtual layer or it's
a piece of software or set of programs
running on top of your machines which
takes care of storing and retrieving of
the data
from different different machines which
are connected over network okay
so let me just give you one example of
that
let's say you have about one terabyte of
file this is one terabyte of file which
you want to store
let's say there are four different
machines physical machines in this
diagram as it is being shown
they are let's say geographically
located differently one is in chicago
one is in austin one is in denver right
and these machines are let's say
connected over a network so they form
one
sorry
they form one uh
cluster okay
let us not worry about what is cluster
we will understand that in the actual
training sessions
so let say you have four physical
machines uh you want to basically
store the data
so this one terabyte of file will be
divided into four different parts part a
part b part c part d
and each part of the file will be stored
in different different machines which
are located geographically in a
different different places
right
so this is a physical storage
but
how does it store so
user will not know that it has to divide
this
file and then store the data into
different machines user it is all
abstracted out from users
so what user does is let's say this is
the file and the file name is let's say
f1 i'll just give some name f1 so if
let's say user stores the data under
some path let's say user
data
f1
that means this is called sdfs path okay
so basically there is one
abstraction or
virtual layer which is running on top of
all these machines
okay
which basically is nothing but not a
it's not a physical file system it's a
set of programs which are running
which will take care of dividing the
data into different different machines
so when you store the data into this
particular location this location is an
sdfs path so user will not know whether
he he will just think that okay i am
storing this data in a particular
location in the in the single machine
okay
but
internally
because it's stored in an sdfs
the uh or basically a distributed file
system
these programs
will intelligently divide this file into
different parts
like this
and store them into different different
machines
so these programs will know remember
which part of the file is stored in
which machine right so next let's say
next day when the user comes and he
wants to retrieve this data or read the
data he will just say cat
and this path okay this entire path that
i have written above okay the same path
so when he just give cat and the
location of the file
he thinks i'm just reading it from the
same machine
but internally this set of programs
which i have just highlighted in this
dotted line
they will actually go and collect all
these parts
read all these parts from different
different machines physically
collate them together
right
and then present them as one big file to
the user right
so this is how
the entire storage and retrieval process
of the data is abstracted out from the
user and that is called and and the set
of programs which are doing it is called
distributed file system so please
remember carefully distributed file
system is not a physical file system it
is just a virtual layer which takes care
of storage and retrieval of the data in
a distributed manner okay
so
hadoop uses a distributed file system to
store the data okay so let me directly
talk about what is hadoop so if you just
want to remember the definition of
hadoop just remember it's this way
hadoop is a framework which allows you
to do two important thing one is called
distributed processing and another one
is called distributed storage right
scale out storage and distributed
processing
so bill if you can just relate it uh
this way let's say you have massive
amount of data which you want to store
right
so when you have a big data which you
want to store the first problem which
you have is
how do i store this data or where should
i store this data correct
and that problem will be taken care by
one of the components
so the processing of the data will be
taken care by another component of photo
which is called map reduce
mr mapreduce okay
so these are the two components
which
is nothing but hadoop
okay so hadoop is a framework
which has two core components sdfs and
reduce okay
so that's what is hadoop
all about right and in our trainings we
will definitely get into the
in detail architecture of these
components we'll do lot of hands-on we
will also cover some of the ecosystem
components of hadoop and also the
architecture and practical sessions of
hands-on exercises of those
components but if you want to remember
what is hadoop this is what hadoop is
sdfs plus mapreduce is equal to hadoop
it has two components
one component deals with the storage of
the data another component deals with
the processing of the data that's it
right if you remember this way you will
never forget what is hadoop okay
so some of the ecosystem component that
i have just
mentioned which is
which are all this right so i'm not
going to talk about the use case and the
overview of these components but these
are the components like flume scope
you already
understood map reduce and sdfs these are
the two core components of hadoop except
these two
all the other components or all the
other keywords or jargons that you have
heard about like hive pig latin mahout
edge base flume scoop uzi
all these are called ecosystem
components of hadoop okay and in our
actual training we will be covering all
these topics in detail with hands-on
exercises all right
so that's pretty much uh that i wanted
to cover for today's session so what we
understood is
what is uh you know big data why big
data is so much important
and what are the technologies that we
can work with big data so hadoop is
definitely one of the most effective
technology to work with big data and in
our actual training we will understand
why hadoop is most effective technology
to work with big data we will compare
hadoop with different technologies and
understand the technical differences of
that right
so we understood what is hadoop we just
understood the overview of hadoop and
the ecosystem components of hadoop right
so i hope all of you have enjoyed this
seminar
i hope all of you have you know
understood whatever we have covered so
far
i will again spend few minutes for
questions so please do let us know if
you have any questions or comments about
this webinar
okay so
let us know if anyone has any questions
any comments
all right
all right then uh thank you everyone for
your time uh we hope you have enjoyed
the sessions looking forward for all of
you to
meet in the actual training classes
thank you so much have a wonderful day
ahead thank you everyone
you